hit it nick you gotta love it vo thorn
schwinn and bribe i got a debate club
for you but first i gotta clear up some
air but a lot of talk about these
delivery boys
ups usps fedex [ __ ] all them boys
i'm talking about them heavy hitters
them 10 speed splitters
boy we talking about them [ __ ] big
packages
that bad baby weighs 49 000 pounds [ __ ]
them three pound packages
leads me to my debate club you're gonna
go in the truck stop
probably dirty as [ __ ] [ __ ] all over the
toilet seat you're gonna wipe it off
with the tp
or you're gonna use that porter john
that job johnny boy you know what i'm
talking about
with the hand sanitizer squirt a little
bit on the tp and wipe off the toilet
seat
let me know what you boys think or you
can just take a [ __ ] in the back of the
truck in a garbage can like i've had to
do a couple times not proud of it
trucks boy i like this dude's energy
yeah yeah
that job johnny dude what are you using
brendan
man my family's truck driver's dog so we
i've had to shin the back myself a few
times when i was a kid yeah i used to go
on the jo
the voyages with them my uncle's still
delivering right now to this day
oh for real denver to la's his track
amen bro
amen we used to play dirty ernie do
where somebody would like
you would put your feet on the dock by
the river you know and
somebody would hold you off like you
hold your arms so say if you were
holding me i'd be like this
and then whoever's getting held off
defecates out into the water yeah
does poop yeah it's not gay [ __ ] dog
you and your friend interlocking fingers
while everyone shuts
the
and what's the game the game here's the
game
well now that i think about the game
it's a little questionable
but so you go as much as you can yeah
and then whenever your buddy wants to he
can let you go
it's not that big of a game really but
dog one time me and my brother worked
for a it's a real time it's a vibe
i feel you we worked at all seasons it
was rental [ __ ] my brother drive the big
rig and i just chill in the seat right
yeah it's called being lazy dude that's
why i got fired
but so we drop off like party supplies
chairs all sorts of [ __ ]
and it was pouring rain outside and i
had to take the biggest [ __ ]
so my brother had this big slurpee cup
i'm like i ain't going out in the rain
he's like you're not [ __ ] him like
yes i am so i went in the back of the
truck
dude you don't realize how much [ __ ] can
fill up a slurpee cup
oh dude i dropped i dropped a hot coil
in that thing
my brother could not stop gagging and
what do you think that does for you
brendan when you oh i got fired no you
got fired yet from there
uh it was a that i think that was the
cherry on the on the on the cake
where they're like we just got to get
rid of you doug it's cherry on sunday
i like cake i don't like sundaes
somebody's been
putting cherries on random foods
the cherry on the steak i think it's
always the last thing no matter what
yeah it's always the last that's the
cherry on the hot dog
that works too dog so now what happened
to it did you did you
i got right well the final thing was we
hated our boss this dude matt he's a
piece of [ __ ]
and he smoked cigarettes all the time so
and he left his cigarettes out one day
because he had to go like talk somebody
so i took the cigarettes and everyone's
like what are you gonna do and i put in
my
butt hole so his cigarettes what this
part he was smoking up has [ __ ] on him
so he came back started smoking the
cigarettes we all started laughing
and i think that was the final cherry on
the steak
i have so many questions i was like 15.
like 15. yeah
why was there still [ __ ] on your
butthole did you not clean it properly
i went deep in there dog oh gosh
that's so nice so shout out to all
seasons in denmark colorado they're
still they're family operated
okay okay i have to confess something
too now
oh god one time in grade school we peed
in water guns and we sprayed them on the
girls in our class we were in like third
grade i feel really bad about it
those are those are kelly superstars
i didn't break the law and open up
federal mail [ __ ]
we're all sharing you're gonna judge me
dude
i'm not this guy was mean to us
[Laughter]
i'll take all the help i can get yeah
you're getting some right now dude
i am asking for help for you man y'all
nasty
yes that's what i want to say chappelle
yeah y'all never did anything like not
you cat y'all y'all never did anything
like that
one time my homie pissed in a water
balloon threw it on my face yeah
hell yeah and then uh one time a friend
slapped dog [ __ ] on my face
i was really drunk southern comfort
night oh
what yeah what's comfortable about that
that ain't something they're interested
in yeah that's me that's
that's y'all never did anything to get
back at bosses or anything nobody ever
changed you like [ __ ] growing up
i'm a nice guy too but i don't need to i
don't need to get them back it'll happen
for them i also don't need to use poop
out of my body to
prove my point you know like i will just
you can poop into the bathroom and then
go prove your point separately
chin you never do anything not like that
but i did something that
i feel terrible about oh let's hear it
tell us about that jen
so my parents obviously are very very
strict right korean parents yeah wow
so me me and my brother and my best
friend cam
we were at a place called westminster
mall we got into a fight
and then the car drove up next to us and
shot at us
so went through our car the one bullet
got stuck right where my door was at but
luckily didn't go through otherwise it
hit my neck
the other one went through the back seat
went under the car and all that stuff
so me and my brother were freaking out
my dad's gonna find out
so me my brother and another friend went
driving around
at night time and we stole like a piece
of a car that looks like ours
so you can't see the bullet you know you
know that little the thing the rubber
rocket yeah yeah so we just drove around
look for a similar car the rubber siding
yeah we just jacked it and then put it
on our car damn check
it out you feel bad about that because i
told you
i stole someone's being asian let's
don't forget they also put a huge
spoiler on the back of the car for no
reason i did too super spooky
they're like hey the car got shot a few
times this is a great time to add an
even bigger sport
that's all let's also add a little
exhaust system that's not the solution
it's just it's just looks oh it's just
oh i thought there was something like
illegal about that
no always just go on i'm sorry no good
the exhaust can be illegal damn chin
went up my story like a [ __ ] oh
chin got shot out driving i know right
yeah i just put
someone's cigarettes in my butt catfish
you almost died too you were don't
afraid we would tell them i'm so
afraid of my dad well that's the thing
wait why were they shooting at you
because they thought we were gangsters
and we didn't act like you know we
weren't gangsters we were just like what
are you gonna do
yeah and this was the 90s man people
shooted asians all the time back then
the l.a riots but i'll say this though
you can tell an asian kid shame by this
inversely by the size of the spoiler on
their car i feel like
i feel like it's directly how is that
not a chart
big's your fin yeah how big your fin huh
how big is your fan how big is your sin
there you go how big you're saying nick
you got nothing i feel like you put some
stuff up your butt
watercolor why are you guys disgusting
there's no
no poo stuff but i told you super
soakers super super yeah
okay all right it's pretty sorry charlie
sorry colleen did you say anything
or not uh no i was never into stuff like
that but i went to
school with a girl who used to like when
she got mad at other girls in the locker
room she would take out like
a used tampon and chase girls around oh
yeah
oh yeah everyone was afraid of her of
course her name was diane
she just [ __ ] she would like take out
a tampon after
p.e she'd walk out and suddenly just see
her like yeah it was like while
everyone was changing like the one girl
who was bullying that hot
one bro right after p.e
she turned into a track star with that
tampon in her hand is she hot
no regular is she hot you pervert she's
under age
well no not if you're both 12 dog
yeah how old were you uh i was like 15
yeah she was not hot
if you're all 15 it's all good where's
she end up
we're not 15 right now oh you don't know
where she's at i don't know where she's
at probably not doing it well she's
listening
i hope you do shout out to you diane i
hope you're doing better i had a good
story i was going to share
it's about you breaking the law again
and judging me
interlocking your hands with other dudes
while you're taking [ __ ]
probably it was a game you were doing no
games
bro y'all don't have any fun man smoke
my gnats bro
how did someone get comfortable enough
to poop in that situation though well
that was the thing
and they had a clock you were on a time
how much time did you have yeah like a
minute
oh wow that's a quick that's disgusting
so yeah
yeah it was like a real you know kind of
real
russian roulette yeah i guess that's
something different
yeah it was just a real you know who's
who he's like a real who's who of the
neighborhood yeah
your games are gay
bro most games kids play are freaking
gay dude
you go hi it's where i'm gonna come find
you we're both men we're both boys
that's gay all the time
yeah hey i'm gonna touch you and run off
that's gay tag
yeah freeze tag kick the can was pretty
good game
let's kick the can it's where you put a
can somewhere
and then somebody's supposed to guard it
y'all know it or something do i know
i know i've heard of it but i've never
really understood it i thought it was a
bigger speech
yeah yeah that was fair speech they
can't because like you you die
mm-hmm
thanks guys it's the cherry on the
bucket
yeah we didn't play kick the king
because we had balls so we'd like play
kickball you know
dude oh my bad guy who's defecating in a
slurpy cup
right while he's on the clock yeah and i
got fired for it dude i get punished
is